[Music]
we don't go to them and say hey we've
got electricity we're going to bring it
to you we're going to bring it modern
entertainment that electricity revived
know they're coming to us and saying
we're so far off the grid we don't have
any electricity we're using kerosene we
have to carry the kerosene hundreds of
miles to our village on a regular
schedule what little electricity you
have is coming from some diesel
generators it's not very efficient it's
not very healthy matter of fact the
fumes are damaging the insides of the
monasteries and things like that so our
bringing electricity dam is for them a
dream come true
[Music]
[Music]
there are some landslides which happened
last month so the roads are not so good
now in good condition and secondly if it
rains it can be really risky for us to
you know even move ahead because if we
go ahead and we get stuck in some area
we can either go back or go forward oh
my god it's it's it's tough
[Music]
what is the natural response for you
when you enter a room that is not lit up
so reach for a light sight to reach for
a light switch and that is something
that these villages have never
experienced actually had tears of joy
just like looking back at the caravan of
vehicles that were all like coming
together to do this amazing thing
together
[Music]